today we're talking about subsea cable
startup sustainability and monitoring
your vms i'm carter morgan and welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
we're excited to announce apricot a new
subsea cable that will connect singapore
japan guam the philippines taiwan and
indonesia it's expected to be ready for
service in 2024
in total we have investments in 18
subsea cables alongside our 27 cloud
regions and 82 zones around the world
check out the blog for more about the
sub seat cables and connectivity
our first ever google cloud startup
summit will be taking place on september
9 2021
google cloud is committed to maximizing
your potential and we know how critical
mentoring and support can be on a
startup journey we hope you will join us
as we bring together our startup
community including startup founders
ctos vcs and google experts to provide
behind-the-scenes insights and inspiring
stories of innovation check out the blog
for a look at the agenda and register
today
a recent google commission study
illustrated the importance of
sustainability for organizations i.t
departments while also revealing that
significant work is needed before
businesses meet their sustainability
goals the good news is that 90 say that
sustainability is a priority for their
i.t departments and as more
organizations consider the benefits of
digital transformation and cloud
migration sustainability is a must-have
or major consideration when evaluating
cloud providers check out the blog to
learn about the obstacles and pathways
to progress and how google cloud can be
supportive
we're happy to announce the general
availability of an enhanced in-context
set of ui-based tools for compute engine
users to help make the troubleshooting
journey easier and more intuitive from
the google console developers can click
into any vm and access a rich set of
pre-built visualizations designed to
give insights into common scenarios and
issues associated with cpu disk memory
networking and live processes
with access to all of this data in one
location you can easily correlate
between signals over a given time frame
check out the blog for more
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see the full list check
out the link and if you have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us and we'll see you in the cloud